So, let's talk about
Development Workflow.
Although details will be different
from organization to organization,
the general ideas will stay the same.
Developers just don't edit code
files on one big file server.
They use version control systems
to track their changes and
keep them in sync.
There are a bunch of different
version control systems out there, but
some of the most important ones these
days are Distributed VCS such as Git.
When a developer writes their change,
they commit it to their fork or
branch of the project.
Then, when their work is ready to be
merged in, they issue a pull request to
the main branch and request a code
review from their colleague.
Then, once the review is done,
they can merge their change in.
So there are various points
that testing can happen.
Developers can manually run tests on
their own code before code review or
as part of that process.
Integration and full system tests
rely on running the whole service,
often on a testing server.
After that, it's common practice to
deploy the changes to a staging server
for further tests.
The difference between a test server and
a staging server is that
the latter resembles production
as closely as possible.
For instance, having real data.
And then, if everything goes well,
the build gets promoted to production.
Depending on the application,
it can be a good idea to
do rollouts incrementally.
So that, even if,
after all this testing, the release
turns out to break the service.
At least it doesn't
break all of it at once.
Even if you never want
to have to use it,
having the ability to
rollback is really important.
As you can see, there were a fair
number of steps in this process.
If the handover from every step to
another was manual, it would be slow and
potentially error prone.
Slow manual processes
create bottlenecks and
errors create extra unplanned work
that uses up time to do planned work.
So, by automating as much as we can, and
making sure that people can fix
the bottlenecks in their work process,
DevOps practices can give us much more
time to do the actual productive work.